hello everyone welcome to this video on
an informed versus informed search in
artificial intelligence by simply learn
and let me tell you guys that we have
regular updates on multiple Technologies
if you're a tech geek on a continuous
hunt for the latest technological Trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and press that Bell icon
to never miss any update from Simply
learn so in this video we will see what
uninformed searches in AI after that we
will cover some key features of
uninformed search algorithms in AI
moving forward we will see an informed
search in AI after that we will cover
some key features of inform search
algorithms in AI lastly we will see the
difference between uninformed and
informed searches algorithm by the end
of this video I can ensure you that all
your questions and doubts related to
informed and uninformed searches will
have been cleared on that note if you
are an expiring AIML engineer then X
lead your career in AIML with a
comprehensive postgraduate program in Ai
and machine learning boost your career
with this Ai and ml course delivered in
collaboration with Purdue University and
IBM learn in demand skills such as
machine learning deep learning NLP
computer vision reinforcement learning
generative AI prompting engineering
charge ability and many more you will
receive a procedure certificate and ask
me anything session by IBM with five
caps soon in different domains using
real data sets you will gain practical
experience master classes by Purdue
University and isbm expert and short
top-notch education simply learn job
assist help you get noticed by Leading
companies this programs cover statistics
python supervisor and supervised
learning NLP neural network comp
division Gans Keras tensorflow and many
more skills enroll now and unlock
exciting aimlc opportunities the link is
in the description box below so without
any further Ado let's get started so
what is uninformed search in here and
inform search algorithm explore problem
spaces without using heuristic
information their Traverse States and
like base fully on problem structure
like default search and breadth first
search with completeness and simplicity
but potentially sacrificing efficiency
in large search spaces moving forward
let's see some features of uninformed
search algorithm in AI the first one is
exclude additional information an inform
search algorithms navigate problem space
solely based on the given problem
structure disregarding any external
information or heuristic guidance that
might Aid an efficient exploration the
second one is attains goal via action
sequence length and order an informed
search determines Solution by traversing
through sequences of action without
considering their individual merits
focusing instead on the order and the
length of actions taken the third one is
Lex knowledge utilization for problem
solving so these algorithms do not
explore additional knowledge or insights
about the problem domain they rely
solely on the problem structure element
and available action the fourth one is
typically it occurs higher cost than
informed search an informed search
methods can lead to substantial path
resulting in potential higher cost to
reach the course rate when compared to
informed search algorithm that leverage
heuristic information the fifth one is
examples BFS DFS breath for search and
depth first search are classic examples
of uninformed search algorithm that
explore State and action without
considering additional information
making decisions solely based on their
structural characteristics
so let's move forward and see what is
inform search in here in AI smart search
methods called inform search use helpful
Clues to find solution faster they use
exercise information like how far things
are from the goal to pick the best path
to check first this helps them to reach
solution more quickly and efficiently
example is including a star and greedy
best first search they often enhance
efficiency compared to uninformed search
by narrowing down same direction
potentially reducing the expiration time
and expanding new feature nodes however
the accuracy of heuristic information
and its computational complexity can
impact their performance
so some features of informed search
algorithm in air the first one is
encompasses goal State information in
form search method incorporate details
about the desired good State allowing
them algorithm to make more informed
decision during the search process
resulting in better path choices the
second one is enhances search efficiency
by utilizing heuristic information
inform search algorithm intelligently
direct exploration towards more
promising path leading to quicker
convergence to solution and often
reducing the overall search effort the
third one is harness knowledge for
search implementation these algorithms
employ heuristic function that estimate
how close a given state is to the goal
State helping prioritize states that are
likely to lead solution the fourth one
is generally lower cost inform search
approaches such as a star search usually
lead to lower cost both in terms of time
and resources by focusing on paths that
are more likely to lead optimal solution
the fifth one is requires less time for
search the use of heuristic information
allows informed search to efficiently
eliminate unpromising search Direction
leading to faster identification of
solution especially in complex problem
spaces moving forward let's see some
difference between informed search and
uninformed search so the first parameter
is utilizing knowledge so in informed
search employees knowledge during the
search process and in uninformed search
does not require knowledge during the
search the second parameter is speed in
informs the solution finding is quicker
and in an informed search solution
finding is comparatively slower the
third parameter is completion in inform
search it can be both complete and
incomplete and in uninformed search
always bound to be complete and the
fourth one is consumption of time in
informed search due to the quicker
search it consumes less time and in
uninformed search due to slower searches
it consume more time the fifth one is
cost so in inform search expenses are
much lower as compared to uninformed
such expenses are comparatively higher
and the sixth one is Direction AI
receives suggestion for solution in
inform search and in uninformed search
AI lacks suggestion for the solution
Direction and the next one is efficiency
cost less generate quicker results in
inform search and in uninformed search
cost more generates slower results and
the next one is length of implementation
so here implementation is shorter and
other side implementation is lengthier
so and the last one is example inform
search examples are Graph Search greedy
search and in unform search BFS and DFS
breadth first search and depth first
search in summary uninformed search
relies solely on the problem structure
and action while inform search leverages
heuristic information to quite the
search process more efficiently and
effectively so and with that we have
come to end of this video on uninformed
search what's the inform search I hope
you found this valuable and entertaining
please ask any question about the topics
covered in this video in the comment
section below now a team of experts will
assist you in addressing your problem
thank you for watching stay safe keep
learning with simply learn staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in Cutting
Edge domains including data science
cloud computing cyber security AI
machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign